so guys this is your second films again
of course the first being like crazy how
did this compare to making like crazy um
I think it was a lot of it was finding
actually a different way of working from
like crazy from taking like crazy and
going okay that was that thing and now
this is a completely new set of people
and a different story and we have to
forget everything it was more about
forgetting in a weird way it wasn't yeah
I mean it's funny it's like the process
changes with the with the players I mean
it's it's it's you know you have to
adapt to the style of of the actors you
have and you know Felicity was was was
still there but everyone else was
different around her so we really had to
adapt to you know who came in and you
know guy really changed the process as
well because he's much more traditional
actor but then by the end of it sort of
completely lost all of that how did you
find it the first time you were taking
on that improv process because it also
you've got a very clear outline for
everything though and for all the scenes
it's very much leaving the camera
rolling isn't it and letting you go free
with it mm-hmm so how does M&E find it
the very first time you came to do that
and how did it compare this time mm well
I I was keen for the second time to be
different from the first one I wanted to
try and find a new character and and and
to to kind of get again to get away from
like crazy and in a strange way and and
it was really useful because you Drake
would let my dad to say that
say whatever guy and I would watch the
rushes from the end of the day at the
end of the day and that was really
interesting being able to kind of chart
your character with and then speak to
Drake about it and be you know I think
we need to do more of this or and to be
collaborative in that way it's exactly
how it's just so difficult reading out
of order when you're improvising because
it's like wait a minute here you know we
know exactly the scene needs to be about
the emotional beats but at the same time
you know you're gonna shoot something
what happens after this ten days later
and it's really important for them to be
able to chart that and to be able to
have an internal sort of sense about
where the character is at all times now
in the film Felicity your character
gives Skye's character piece of advice
which is not to let fear become his
profession I wondered if either of you
had a particular advice you remember
that you hold dear either for your own
life
you work at you've gone along um wow
that's a good question I think I forgot
everything I've learned so yeah it's so
easy to listen to advice but then to
actually employ it into your own life
it's so hard I think something I
remember someone saying to me never
worry
oh it's say say what you I mean always
that thing they say what you feel what
is it it's the end of King Lear I must
say what we feel not what we ought to
say well something about sounding too
pretentious but yeah something it's
something along those lines like no
matter what the situation is don't worry
if you're gonna lose your job work you
know if you feel something very strongly
then say it and of course you're talking
about getting nervous before auditions
as well because you're both musicians
guy and your characters as well and I
wondered how nervous do you get do four
editions and and how nervous you both
get before a film starts rolling as well
a new project I know if you're not
nervous I think there's something wrong
cuz you're being a little bit um lazy
perhaps I think the kids it's not the
care it's like you made it you know
within a certain bubble and in a way and
you were feeling and thinking about
those things when you made it and it's
important to sort of let that go and say
well that's a piece of me from you know
a year and a half ago or two years ago
and there it is and you move on to the
next thing but the same time you just
kind of have to like trust your
instincts at the time and let it go and
you know to work for some people and it
won't for others but you know that's
that's what's so great about the medium
exactly definitely congratulations you
wouldn't any very more that I've had
that you're moving on to work with
Nathan Parker he won't mean what can we
expect for that something very different
it's gonna be a scripted project there
will be some improv within it but it's
gonna be very sort of traditional in
that sense and a bigger different sort
of genre for me as well can we look
forward to more work for you tea
together because I believe that some
breathe in was started with an idea of
Felicity in mind and certainly I hope so
hi um I'm Felicity of course we know you
so much for all the great indie
films that you might be moving onto a
big superhero blockbuster project with
the amazing spider-man 2 how does it
feel working on something like Lance
uh I really enjoyed it because it was so
different from anything I've ever done
before and just testing a different
thing in you as an actor since the scale
it's just so enormous but I had a really
good fun time you're looking forward to
everyone seeing you as black cat finally
um well possibly I don't know yeah I
kind of it's um
yeah if that happens that would be
wonderful yes
you